salut comment est ce que vous allez bien
aujourd'hui j'espère vous allez bientôt
roule pour vous tout se passe bien que
la vie est belle essayer ça aujourd'hui
on vient de paraître deux produits hors
espagne de montres de nous parler de la
grecque si watch 5 et la galaxie watch 5
pro 2 nouvelles manquantes a présenté il
ya pas très longtemps par samsung en
même temps que les nouveaux smartphones
qui se plient à savoir le samsung galaxy
z philippe iv est folle de quatre on a
également des écouteurs les galaxies
buzz de pro bref je vous ai présenté
déjà tous les autres produits restait
plus que les montres à venir regarder on
vous donnait un peu mon retour ça fait
dix jours que je les ai au poly à gauche
la galaxie ou h5 pro et j'ai ici la
watch sanguin peut plus standard donc on
va regarder aujourd'hui ce qu'il en est
quelles sont les vraies différences on a
une vraie différence de prix on va tous
regarder voir ce qu'il en est s'il y en
a une qui est fait pour vous plus que
l'autre vous êtes prêt vous êtes bien
installé chez vous il va vous allez
barreau sais pas
[Musique]
alors la première chose à voir et à
connaître c'est les tarifs la différence
de prix vous avez différentes config
pour vraiment qu'on re ci dessus qu'on
sache de quoi on parle là on va se
parler de la watch 5la watch s'inquiète
de base alors vous avez deux versions
vous avez une version 40 et vous avez
une version qui en 44 mm ça dépend de la
taille de votre poignet bien évidemment
vous avez aussi une version bluetooth et
vous avez une version bluetooth et 4g
bien évidemment donc 140 mm en bluetooth
vous êtes à
299 euros donc ses tarifs de base vous
montez à 329 euros si vous prenez la
taille un peu plus grande et si vous
êtes en 4g vous êtes tout de suite à 449
euros et là vous passez à 418 euros 90
allez on va dire 419 euros et pas
beaucoup de place ce sont les tarifs de
la watch 5 et vous avez bien évidemment
plough cinq pros donc on va juste se
mettre trop là vous avez une seule
taille vous êtes à 429 euros sur la
version bluetooth et si vous voulez la
version 4g vous êtes à 519 euros ce qui
est important c'est la taille là vous
êtes sûre du 45 mm donc déjà 45 mm c'est
une taille unique à c'est celle que j'ai
là elle est quand même relativement
grande relativement mastoc alors moi
j'ai pas des très grands poignet et ça
va je m'en sors comparé à l'autre
s'éduque hareng donc vous voyez là vous
avez le 45 là vous avez 40 on doit
vraiment une grosse différence de taille
alors très honnêtement j'ai pas d
énormes foyer l'a40 ne va bien c'est
vrai que la taille du cadran est pas
énorme j'en voudrais un peu plus grand
nombre soit 44 me raimu à moi maintenant
le 45 ne trouve pas d'écho n'en très
honnêtement à mon poignet donc bon si
vous avez comme moi dépôt n'y ait pas
trop gros vous pourrez prendre les deux
je conseille quand même vu la taille de
mon voyage aurait pris un peu plus grand
mais voilà oui la différence côte à côte
donc voyez en termes de prix il ya quand
même quelque chose qu'ils jouent et qui
est quand même vachement vachement
important et c'est vraiment tout ce qui
doit guider votre choix voyez si vous
êtes sûre du 44 mm on va me dire
comparer du 44 si vous prenez du 40e ra
un peu moins cher et tant mieux mais
voyons va rester sur les version
bluetooth parce que pour moi les version
4g on s'en fout un peu ces deux là ici
ne vous avait pas forcément besoin d'une
piscine la plupart du temps on va avoir
notre smartphone qui est tout le temps
avec nous alors peut-être davantage sur
la version pro parce que c'est vraiment
la montre qui a fait plus pour les
aventuriers on va vouloir aller courir
par exemple avec ça monte sans savoir
son smartphone ça peut être intéressant
ce moment là et pourquoi pas sur la
version au classicisme à 519 euros on va
vraiment venir se concentrer nous
aujourd'hui sur le 44 en 329 euros
versus celle là qui coûte quand même 100
euros de plus on va donc regarder ce
qu'on a pour 100 euros de plus alors
vous me direz on pourra regarder la 46e
delta qui encore un peu plus grand nous
on va essayer de comparer détails qui
sont à peu près les mêmes 44 45 vous
allez voir que pour cent balles de plus
vous avez un petit peu de différence un
petit peu mais elle est quand même
plutôt pas mal alors avant de regarder
cette partie là on va regarder en termes
de design d'intérieur table de confort
en termes d'ergonomie la différence
allait vraiment significatif pour le
coup à savoir que sur votre watch 5
classique et bien vous avez un petit
bracelet comme ça qui va venir sans
enlever alors des bracelets il y en a
des tonnes autant plus que sur ce modèle
là vous avez l'abysse poke édition la
bespoke édition pour venir la
personnaliser chez samsung modifier les
couleurs essayer ça il ya plein de
différentes couleurs de brassens est
très très chouette donc ça c'est pour la
watch 5 un petit peu standard est le
modèle professionnel à samedi ouverture
qui est beaucoup mieux pensé lors d un
bracelet est un petit peu plus joli jeu
trop avec ce petit truc au milieu alors
vous avez soit comme ça soit noir il
n'ya pas trente six mille couleurs je
leur ai dit un petit peu là voyez là ici
pour autant ça fait dix jours que
j'allais au poignet mais il ya déjà des
marques alors bon je vis avec tous les
jours alors là sur le modèle
professionnel voyez on a une petite
avancée sur le côté donc sur les deux
montres on est en saphir c'est quand
même plutôt pas trop mal protégé donc ça
je trouve ça déjà vachement bien donc ça
ça vient de protéger davantage sur le
modèle professionnel tandis qu sans
l'autre et bien voyez vous n'avez pas de
petites avancées c'est directement la
montre bien que vous soyez en saphir
vous allez potentiellement vachement
plus cogner sur la ouache 5e sur loud
cinq pros où vous êtes quand même un
petit peu plus protégé vous avez ce
petit gars de foulard dans les deux cas
vous avez un verre en saphir qui sera un
peu plus résistant que la plupart des
liens standard mais ce qui m'intéresse
vachement moi c'est le thème d'ouverture
regarder je viens et je le louvre comme
ça en fait donc ça se trouve ça
extrêmement mal un an qu'en fait ça me
permet d'avoir une ouverture où je vais
pas venir m'arracher et bien le poignet
je viens de refermer très rapidement je
viens juste en fait le régler la voyez
avec un petit système de réglettes qui
vient se lever là et ensuite je fais
glisser cette partie là comme ça je peux
adapter très très facilement avec de mon
panier donc ça s'est assez mal alors il
faut venir les régler au niveau des bus
on tâtonne un peu puis une fois que
c'est réglé ça se positionne très
facilement ça ne bouge pas très
honnêtement je trouve que ça bouge pas
facilement résistants donc ça c'est
vachement cool donc voilà je préfère
vraiment vraiment cette ouverture là sur
la montre pro que sur l'autre autre
différence notable vous le voyez je
pense directement bien la preuve quand
même vachement plus épaisse que l'autre
modèle il ya un côté qu' un peu plus
mastoc alors il vous le 10 ans et la
montre pour les aventuriers c'est la
montre pour les baroudeurs la demande
donc professionnels que vous allez
emmener partout avec vous donc
fatalement et bien j'ai passé pour ça
ils nous ont bien bloque un peu plus
épais mais après vous allez voir qu'à
l'intérieur c'est exactement la même
chose on a exactement les mêmes capteurs
dans une montre que dans l'autre on a
une batterie sur la montre sur la
professionnelle qui est de 590 millions
terreur versus 410000 et en paire eur /
la montre en 44 et sur la montre comme
j'ai là en 40 on à 294 millions
inférieur l'envoyer il ya quand même une
différence de batteries j'ai pas relevé
de grosses différences d'autonomie entre
les deux montres je vais recharger à peu
près à la même fréquence pour autant sur
papier on nous annonce que sur la watch
5 standard on a jusqu'à 40 heures et sur
la proue sec 80 heures très honnêtement
j'ai pas senti une énorme différence là
si vraiment ça ça m'a pas choqué je les
ai recharger à peu près toutes les deux
à intervalles réguliers dont je sais pas
je vois pas vraiment vous dire là dessus
mais en tout cas les deux sont plutôt
bien alors autre grosse différence sur
loud 5 vous avez un petit boîtier en
aluminium que bianchi plutôt d'office je
vous dis la différence surtout cette
partie là disent que là vous êtes sûre
du titane dont ils ont vraiment fait un
truc résistant pour ceux qui veulent
aller se balader qui veulent pas prendre
de risque pour casser leur montre voilà
donc ça c'est vachement cool donc on a
un peu plus de résistance il faut savoir
que dans les deux cas vous avez
exactement la même résistance les mêmes
étanchéité à l'eau donc si elle
rencontre de l'eau douce y a pas de
souci à savoir que vous avez vous dit
même processeur vous avez la même rame
vous avez le même stockage vous avez
tous les mêmes capteurs mise à part le
design pour l'instant on n'a pas encore
vu de quelque chose qui change
énormément et mise à part la taille du
cadran 44 versus 45 ça se tient un peu
quand même la différence est notable
c'est que sur loud 5 on va pouvoir venir
plus la customiser la personnaliser pour
tous les jours pour la mode pour du
lifestyle si vous voulez vraiment venir
module est modifié en tout cas votre
montre c'est peut-être plus là dessus
qu'on va venir partir alors couleurs de
la montre vous avez du graphite de
l'argent et du bleu ça c'est vraiment
pour votre montre au niveau de
l'aluminium par contre pour tout le
reste eh bien voyez vous avez un nombre
de croquis quand même assez exhaustif la
vente bleu blanc vert gris olive crème
grafite dont vous choisissez vraiment ce
que vous voulez et vous pouvez venir en
plus moduler la taille de votre bracelet
or c'est la même chose assez compris
dedans small medium ou médium large ça
dépendra bien évidemment de tout à
chacun tandis que si vous regardez sur
la watch cinq projets bien et arrive
donc je vois que la montre je vais
l'avoir soit en titane soit en couleur
noire et là je vais avoir donc sommes
enfin marc magnétique comme je vous ai
montré c'est ce que je préfère très
honnêtement vous avec deux couleurs le
noir ou gris ou alors vous choisissez
d'autres teintes un peu plus lifestyle
ou là effectivement on pourra revenir
aller dans ce sens là mais moi ce que
j'aime vraiment cette ferme à magnétique
je trouve vachement plus pratique
beaucoup plus jolie fille plutôt qu'à
voir cette partie là qui est un peu plus
standard donc ça c'est à vous de voir
une fois de plus à des différences de
taille qu'on pourra retrouver ici tout
en sachant que cette customisation c'est
l'habit spock studio et bien vous
l'aurez ici uniquement sur samsung
points comme donc si ça vous intéresse
vous est bien évidemment un lien
justement dans la description maintenant
il ya un vrai tronc commun entre ces
deux mondes c'est à dire vous allez
faire sensiblement la même chose entre
ces deux mondes alors je vous explique
pourquoi on serait capitule un petit peu
ça aujourd'hui je prends un peu ce titre
je n'ai pas pris de grandes feuilles
blanches pour vous montrer tout ça le
tronc commun ils reposent sur trois
parties on va avoir le suivi de santé
donc toute la partie santé connectés et
je vous détaille ça dans quelques
secondes on va voir le sport qui est
aussi un élément extrêmement important
alors le sport la santé c'est tout
interconnecté bien évidemment et puis
vous avez le troisième ace c'est le
sommeil donc on a ces trois aces lui est
vraiment le tronc commun qui est
extrêmement important alors vous
expliquent déjà toute la partie santé
alors la partie santé regardez vous
allez venir voir c'est très simple vous
venez ici dans votre montre et vous
venez dans vos paramètres et vous allez
pouvoir retrouver ici notamment
l'attention et le cg alors l'attention
ce avec la mesure de votre tension de
votre pression artérielle un instant t
bien évidemment et puis le cg c'est
l'électro cardiogramme ça va être la
mesure de votre rythme cardiaque pour
voir si vous avez un trouble du rythme
donc ces trucs là sont plutôt bien mais
pour moi il ya un truc un peu bloquant
au niveau de la tension c'est au niveau
de la calibration vous venez calibré
vêtements pour le suivi de tension mais
il vous faut un tensiomètre ça veut dire
que si vous n'avez pas de tension dans
le suivi de tension vous n'avez pas
pouvoir le faire ou alors il faudrait
dans une pharmacie pour prendre votre
tension est calibré votre montre ou
alors le faire directement chez votre
toubib autant vous dire que c'est quand
même un petit peu contraignant vous
devez aller directement dans votre
smartphone et vous venez calibré votre
montre et je trouve ça ça pose vraiment
des contraintes fortes alors une fois
que c'est fait c'est fait c'est vous
êtes penhars effet mais si vous n'avez
pas de tensiomètres chez vous si vous
n'allez pas dans une pharmacie pour
venir le fada vous ne pouvez pas
utiliser cette fonction de tension donc
ça c'est un peu con après vous avez
l'autre fonction avec l'électro
cardiogramme alors pour mesurer votre
votre cg c'est assez facile alors je
vous montre il faut que vous posiez up
votre montre là elle est fixée vous l'a
fixé bien en haut du poignet gauche et
ensuite vous venez poser votre doigt et
là vous ne bougez pas leur faut pas
parler il faut pas bouger lors ils vous
expliquent bien qu'effectivement ça ne
permet pas de savoir si vous avez fait
une crise cardiaque ou si vous faites
une crise cardiaque c'est une mesure un
petit peu de routine pour vous dire si
vous avez un trouble du rythme donc la
voyez vous avez 30 secondes à venir
attendre vous avez les bpm alors ce que
je trouve assez intéressant là dedans et
vous allez le voir dans votre
application samsung health samsung santé
et relais voilà il vous le marx et ses
gènes pas de signes de fabrication
auriculaire donc ça ok ça va bien j'ai
un rythme sinusal tout va bien et
ensuite vous retrouver tous directement
ici dans votre application voyez j'ai
mon rapport de cg keira et là j'arrive
alors vous allez voir toutes les
informations sur moi et vous verrez donc
voilà les données médicales vous livriez
directement alors ça ça doit être au
début lorsque je me mets à parler et que
c'est un peu le bazar mais sinon voyez
donc j'ai bougé un autre un peu le bazar
mais en effet un tout à l'heure juste
avant qu'ils étaient un peu plus calme
voilà celui là où on voit
qu'effectivement tout de suite c'est
beaucoup plus normal ça ne bouge pas et
vous le montre un rythme sinusal cette
saison montrent pas de signes de
fabrication récupérer après je peux
venir le partage et je peux voir un pdf
l'avenir l'envoyer à un médecin si
besoin voilà donc bon il ya d'la données
de santé je trouve ça quand même plutôt
pas mal fichu ici vous avez toutes vos
données qui sont situées juste là ok ça
me conviendra et puis vous avez un autre
truc qui aussi vachement bien qu'ils se
situent juste dans cette application là
à le voir la composition corporelle
alors la composition corporelle elle est
vachement bien vous prenez vous posez
vous étirer garde rsg toutes les
informations pour la mesure et vous
appuyez l'avouer hop là ça c'est le
poids comme ça vous connaissez mon poids
et vous connaissez je pose mes deux
doigts comme ça voilà majeur et
l'annulaire et je bouge pas ça fait le
taff ça vient alors moi vous savez que
le tremblement essentiel toujours un
petit peu la teuf donc là me demande de
ne pas bouger mais bon je fais comme je
peux mon copain il mesure ma composition
corporelle et ensuite j'ai toutes les
informations au niveau de mon poids de
muscles squelettiques
alors je vois ce qui va je vois ce qu'il
veut pas donc c'est donner je trouve
quand même plutôt bien et fiable j'ai
comparé avec une balance qui fait la
même chose ça fonctionne plutôt bien et
ça vous donne des données de santé une
fois de plus pour nous suivre votre
composition corporelle voir où est ce
que vous en êtes vous avez un imc l'imc
celle indice de masse corporelle ça vous
si vous voulez vraiment aligner toutes
les données de santé vous avez quand
même pas mal d'indicateurs ici ça ce
sont les trois choses convient
aujourd'hui voir directement ici qu'on
peut venir utiliser avec cette montre
simplement après il ya un autre point
qui est vachement important c'est toute
la question du sport alors la question
du sport on la retrouve sur les deux
mondes c'est à dire que si vous êtes
sportif vous allez courir vous allez
marcher vous avez plus de 90 mode de
sport qui sont connus ici pour revenir
un peu en arrière et une année avant
2021 c'est la première fois que google
s'est associé à samsung pour proposer
une expérience personnalisée samsung
google were os dédié justement sur ces
mondes samsung avant c'était une
expérience maison de samsung donc la
satar mais plusieurs choses webos qui
sont vachement intéressante déjà d'avoir
une expérience qui est très clair très
simple genre c'est très très vite vous
venez là vous avez vos petits raccourcis
très facilement vous avez vos
notifications sur le côté vous allez
avoir des paramètres rapide ici est
notamment liée bien d'activité du jour
mais différents sports monde et inherent
r je veux dire à mes informations
effectivement je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure sur ma composition corporelle
mon sommeil la météo mon agenda ma
tension monte de cg mais dtm mon stress
que ce souvenir mesuré je peux rajouter
des cartes directement et sinon on va
bien s'intéresser nous tout de suite et
bien toute la partie sport et dans cette
partie sport effectivement et bien je
vois pas mal d'entraînement tout en
sachant que comme on est ici sur ios on
a lu plextor à peut venir télécharger
moult application donc ça c'est chouette
allez on va dire par exemple qu'on veut
faire de la marche 3 2 1 c'est parti
vous êtes prêt allez on y va et là on
est parti pour de la marche ça va venir
traquer marche ça va venir me donner la
distance le nombre de pas voilà donc
pour c'est très pratique alors je viens
ensuite fallu mettre en pause le
terminer ici et ça on va le train mais
y'en a pas besoin mais voyez si vous
voulez par exemple aller marcher faire
beaucoup de sport on va regarder on a
quoi on à la marche on à la course le
vélo la natation entraînement bout
divers et variés en train de m'en de
circuits natation extérieur la rondo
c'est quoi ça la machine à musculation
le vélo d'appartement le tapis de course
notre vélo elliptique et vous prévenir
en ajouter donc elle a quand même pas
mal donc pour tout ce qui va être sport
je dirais déjà vous avez quelque chose
qui est très très très complet et très
très cool ensuite vous retrouvez deux
boutons un petit bouton on revient à
l'écran d'accueil et puis le bouton du
bas et puis ensuite vous allez sur le
bas vous retrouvez toutes vos
applications ici vos paramètres vous
venez naviguer enfin voila c du rer
c'est simple c'est clair ça marche bien
et vous pouvoir mettre autant que vous
voulez à vous de voir je vous le dis et
époque d'application il est quand même
divers et variés puis une cesse de
grossir donc je trouve ça quand même
vachement cool donc là vous avez une
montre connectés qui est complète aussi
également au niveau du sport et puis le
dernier item qui vachement important
c'est toute la partie soleil où on va
venir traquer votre sommeil et savoir ce
qui se passe ça se passe également dans
votre application de santé vous venez
l'activité quotidienne le nombre de pas
l'exercice la nourriture le sommeil vous
venez dans votre application sur votre
smartphone samsung health et là j'ai le
sommeil alors j'ai dormi avec d'autres
nuit mais pas cette dernière qu'est ce
que je vais avoir comme données par
exemple mettre sur le 21 dans mean 9h44
mais qu'est ce qui s'était passé c'est
beaucoup je vois effectivement tout mais
mes phases de sommeil avec les phases
d'éveil ya quand même quelques unes
c'est un peu le bazar le sommeil
paradoxal le sommeil léger le sommeil
profond mais paradoxe assez là où vous
rêvez et le sommeil profond ça va
sûrement ce qui va être récupérateur
dont vous voyez comment montceau mais
c'est un peu le bordel - temps pas très
bien je sais pas si ça vous intéresse
mais ça vous savez tout vous voyez le
nombre d'heures d'éveil le nom de
sommeil profond d'ordre c'est quand même
pas beaucoup je pense que je suis pas un
spécialiste en ce domaine là et puis
vous pouvez venir capter les ronflements
alors c'est pareil pour venir capter les
ronflements il faut que votre smartphone
soit à côté de votre tronche que votre
monde soit à côté moi j'aime bien dormir
la nuit en 10 h repas souvent avec une
montre là j'étais vraiment pour le test
mais la plupart du temps je mets mon
téléphone en mode avion parce que je
peux avoir des ondes pendant des heures
à côté de ma tête donc voyez vous
avancez tout un tracking pendant des
heures là j'avais quand même vachement
moins bien dormi ces faits or à 7h46 ça
va je n'ai fais quoi là hop là c'est bon
vous n'osez pas tout voyez là par
exemple nous sommes restés un peu
différent un peu plus de sommeil profond
donc à 10 ou 1h 1h 13 l'oxygène dans le
sang pendant le sommeil inférieur à 90%
pour 13 secondes voilà principalement ce
qu'on vient maintenant qu'on peut venir
traquer son sommeil ce aussi un élément
de santé qui est vachement vachement
important donc ça c'est vraiment le
tronc commun direct maintenant ce qui va
faire la différence et la
différenciation de l'autre montre ça va
être toute la partie de le mettre hors
d'eau ça va être la partie gps c'est
vraiment le truc qui est important comme
en fait il vous décris vraiment lawati
cinq pros comme étant le monde dédié
pour les aventuriers bien regarder
petite option en plus pour les
aventuriers et lorsque vous allez venir
vous faire un circuit très venir vous
guider sur votre montre soit par un
notification soit dans vos boîtes si
vous écoutez vous à niveau baisse
d'écouter de la musique vous aurez
également dans vos oreilles soit par
vibration ça va vous indiquez votre
chemin jusqu'à l'endroit vous voulez
allez même pouvoir avoir différents
points pendant votre chemin et puis
ensuite à la face à vous donner le bon
chemin pour retourner à votre point de
départ c'est ça la vraie grosse
différence qu'on retrouve en termes de
fonctionnalités c'est cette partie je
pars à l'aventuré jeu parcourir je pars
sur les chemins et à ce moment là je
sais que ma montre elle va nous guider
très facilement et en termes d'usagés
lure est dur c'est la vraie grosse
différence au delà d'avoir un bracelet
un petit peu différent au delà d'avoir
du titane au delà d'avoir un design un
petit peu différent la vraie grosse
différence se situe du côté du gps des
options que vous allez avoir au niveau
du gps alors bien évidemment on a une
différence de taille olive des écrans
l'ag du 1,2 pouce sur l'awadh 5 ch et
une résolution de 396 par 396 c'est du
super amoled dans un cas comme dans
l'autre ici je vais avoir un écran de
1,4 pouces 450 par 450 tu peux venir
personnalisé bien évidemment mes écrans
dont ses héros et ça c'est très facile
je viens choisir ce que je veux j'ai des
tonnes d'écran je peux rajouter moi
j'aimais bien ce côté très très
printanier faut ça chouette donc ça je
le garde vous avez aussi bien des petits
emoji animé on peut faire un peu tout ce
qu'on veut non ça c'est plutôt bien
aussi on annonce une batterie 13%
amélioré par rapport à la génération
précédente ce que je trouve intéressant
c'est qu'on ait de la recherche qui est
quand même vachement rapide votre monde
vous la recharge est très rapidement un
truc qui m'a aussi vraiment surpris et
bleu fait à une époque les montres met
un petit peu de temps pour les recharges
et aujourd'hui ça va très vite et vu que
moi j'en ai dû recharger il ya envoyé up
la jemaye d'un coup aux plages mais de
l'autre est ce assez rapide pour être un
peu technique vous avez à du bluetooth
5.2 vous avez à 16 giga de stockage d'un
côté comme de l'autre vous avez bien
évidemment du nfc pour samsung paix ou
pour google paye et une montre qui va
être un peu plus lourd sur le modèle
professionnel on est à 46 25 grammes
tandis que la cote est redescendu 33 200
g très honnêtement moi d'un côté comme
de l'autre il ya rien qui me dérange
pour faire un peu un bilan final au delà
de la différence de crise je dirais que
si votre truc à vous c'est une mode
connecté qui vous servira pour avoir vos
notifications pour venir à passer vos
appels pour pouvoir gérer tout ce que
vous voulez dans l'écosystème google
parce qu'on est sur une monde google
parce qu'on est sur du verre ou est ce
même si c'est le nom de samsung est bien
là où cinq suffira largement elle est
jolie elle est super design aller très
classe je la trouve vraiment hyper canon
il va falloir choisir votre taille je ne
pense pas que la version 4g soit
extrêmement intéressant donc ça ne vient
pas du tout la recommander de temps
sachant pas ce que vous n'aurez pas
votre smartphone à côté auquel cas on se
dit oui sinon on dit non ça on vient le
dégager pour qu'en fonction de la taille
de votre poignet on va venir regarder ce
qu'on va préférer soit du 40 mm sur du
44 mm bon il ya quand même un certain
delta au niveau du tarif vous avez 30
euros d'écart maintenant si vous avez
réellement besoin de jeu pas au fait de
l'ultra trail vous partez en montagne
vous bouger beaucoup et vous voulez pas
forcément emmener votre smartphone ce
que je vous déconseille si vous passez
dans des coins isolés et bien vous avez
quand même votre montre là avec une vie
sim ce qui est plutôt pas mal 519 euros
ce chiffre quand même pas mal mais si
vous pouvez emmener votre smartphone
vous partez sur la version à 4 129 euros
donc on voit qu'ici on a quand même sans
bal décalé sans mal des cars savez de
quoi ça va être le fait d'avoir un beau
tir un peu plus grand surtout le fait
d'avoir du titane c'est le fait d'avoir
bracelet qui va toujours un peu plus
joli avec un fermoir vachement plus
pratique est vachement plus sexy et
c'est le fait d'avoir cette
fonctionnalité au niveau du gps qui va
être beaucoup plus poussé que ce que
vous avez sur l'awadh 5 donc si vous
faites de l'outdoor si vous courez
énormément vous avez beaucoup dehors et
que vous êtes un petit peu un aventurier
on part sur la pro directement dans la
mesure où 45 mm vous ira bien si
maintenant vous voulez une belle montre
connectés de samsung et que vous voulez
pas venir si vous entendent du bruit
c'est qu'est la machine à laver qui
tourne c'est tout soyez tranquilliser ya
pas des choses bizarres qui se passe par
là si maintenant vous voulez une belle
montre connectés samsung avec une très
belle expérience derrière google et bien
vous partez sur ce modèle là soit encore
en dessous en 44 vous paierez quand même
moins cher la différence au niveau du
gps et de la finition voilà mon retour
voilà mon sentiment moi je les ai bien
aimé toutes les deux j'ai bien aimé
l'expérience j'ai trouvé chouette mais
c'est vrai que même si la 5 pro un petit
truc en plus au niveau du design je vous
conseille quand même de partir sur l'a5
moins chers et tout autant pratique dans
la mesure où on n'allait pas être féru
d'outdoor avoir des besoins de cette
fonction de gps le dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez vous partiriez sur
laquelle photo tim howard 5 plutôt qu
sim watch cinq professionnels est ce
qu'un modèle déjà qui vous botte ici
mark et moi tout ça juste en bas dans
les commentaires et puis je crois qu'on
a fait le tour des nouveautés samsung
pour cette rentrée on a testé bien
évidemment le galaxy z flip 4 on a testé
aussi le z folle de quatre il ya le test
est disponible sur ma chaîne on a
regardé les galaxies buzz de pro donc si
vous voulez et ça c'est un des points et
après vous ferez un gros bisou et bien
c'est une notion d'écosystème complet si
vous voulez des choses qui s'aligne
parfaitement complètement je vous
conseille quand même si vous voulez une
montre de sa mission ou un smartphone de
samsung de venir prendre des choses
qu'ils restent chez samsung pourquoi
parce que c'est tout optimisé pour ça
marche le mieux ensemble et la machine à
laver devient complètement folle à côté
puis ça vous êtes sûr que vous aurez la
meilleure expérience donc si vous voulez
un smartphone vous me prenez une galaxie
web est aussi un modèle de l'année
dernière vous prenez des galaxies buzz
buzz de pros sont très très bon comme ça
vous avez la complète il vous est ce que
ça fonctionne parfaitement bien voilà
c'est fini je vous embrasse prenez soin
de vous surtout dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas dans les commentaires à
très vite des bisous ciao
[Musique]